nous partons tout de suite à berlin
maintenant session extraordinaire du
bundestag aujourd'hui fait extrêmement
rare le chancelier olaf scholz doit
s'exprimer sur l'invasion de l'ukraine
par la russie berlin a pour la première
fois depuis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale autoriser la livraison d'armes
on retrouva de mme hayem notre
correspondante c'est un tournant de la
politique allemande en matière
d'engagement militaire
oui c'est même un changement de
paradigme qui est en train de s'opérer
en allemagne puisque vous l'avez rappelé
l'allemagne après de longues hésitations
a finalement accepté de procéder à des
livraisons d'armes à l'ukraine des armes
qui proviennent de l'inventaire de la
bundeswehr à savoir un millier de lance
roquettes anti char et 500 missiles
sol-air l'allemagne a également donné
l'autorisation aux pays bas et à
l'estonie de fournir des armes provenant
d'allemagne à l'ukraine et c'est donc un
tabou qui tombe dans un pays qui vous le
savez a pour tradition et à quelques
exceptions près de ne pas fournir
d'armes létales dans des zones de guerre
alors évidemment aujourd'hui olaf scholz
va devoir expliquer devant le parlement
ce tournant majeur de la politique
allemande il va surtout devoir également
convaincre son opinion publique car les
allemands ont tendance à se percevoir
comme une nation pacifiste un sondage
publié pas plus tard que jeudi montré
que 68 % des allemands étaient encore
opposés à des livraisons d'armes à
l'ukraine mais ça c'était évidemment
avant que la guerre n'éclate dans le
pays on aperçoit à l'image on a aperçu
et ne suis pas un ancien ministre de la
santé est la ministre allemand des
affaires étrangères anna lena baer boeck
et le miz l'économie robert avec par
ailleurs comment s'explique le
changement de la position allemande
écoutez la guerre en ukraine ébranle les
fondements mêmes de la diplomatie de la
politique étrangère allemande de berlin
a toujours cherché à maintenir le
dialogue avec vladimir poutine a cherché
à multiplier les échanges commerciaux
avec la russie en fait berlin pendant
des décennies a poursuivi ce que l'on
appelle ici la stratégie du vendeur
haendel la stratégie du changement par
le commerce est idée qui veut que la
multiplication des échanges commerciaux
peut contribuer à une libéralisation
dans des pays comme la russie ou la
chine est aujourd'hui et bien l'allemand
l'allemagne se rend compte que c'était
une erreur stratégique majeure
puisqu'elle s'est rendue dépendante des
importations de gaz et de charbon
russell s'est rendue dépendante dans une
moindre mesure aussi des importations de
pétrole de nombreuses entreprises ont
continué à investir ces dernières années
plus de 7 milliards d'euros ces cinq
dernières années selon la chambre du
commerce et de l'industrie germano-russe
alors même que l'invasion de la crimée à
véhicules lieu en 2014 et berlin réalise
aujourd'hui et bien que cette stratégie
d'apaisement vis-à-vis de vladimir
poutine n'a tout simplement pas
fonctionné elle est obligée d'en tirer
les leçons et les allemands ont donc
insisté pour que l'exclusion de la
russie du système swift soit fait de
manière ciblée pourquoi
et bien tout simplement parce que
l'allemagne s'est rendu très dépendante
des importations que je vous le disais
un de gaz de charbon de pétrole russe et
lorsque l'allemagne achète ces matières
premières à la russie et bien les
paiements s'effectuent par le système
inter bancaire swift est donc depuis des
jours le gouvernement allemand
différents membres du gouvernement
allemand mettait en garde contre une
exclusion complète de la russie du
système bancaire à interbancaire swift
gars finalement cette arme que l'on à
cette fonction que l'on appelle l'arme
atomique financière aurait eu un contre
coup majeur pour les allemands et c'est
la raison pour laquelle l allemagne si
c'était pour pour que cette exclusion ne
soit que partiel pour qu'elle puisse
continuer à s'approvisionner en matières
premières car ici on craint évidemment
que la russie coupe le gaz
coupleux et approvisionnement en charbon
et cela pourrait aussi déstabiliser
l'allemagne en bout du au bout du compte
et justement qu'elle pourrait être
quelles peuvent être les alternatifs
pour elle
j'ai envie de vous dire que toutes les
alternatives auront forcément un prix
très élevé alors effectivement
l'allemagne si elle est coupée du gaz
des approvisionnements en matières
premières provenant de russie pourrait
se tourner vers d'autres marchés pour se
fournir en matière première mais un coût
nettement plus élevé bien sûr en tout
cas depuis des jours le ministre de
l'économie et du climat roberta bec près
par les allemands à une augmentation
significative des prix de l'énergie ici
en allemagne et puis en mai en même
temps c'est considérer certains
considèrent aussi ici cette crise comme
une chance finalement pour l'allemagne
une chance de pouvoir se libérer plus
rapidement que prévu de cette dépendance
aux matières premières russes et cela
passerait évidemment par une
des investissements majeurs dans le
développement des énergies renouvelables
pour compenser ses approvisionnements en
matières premières et cela évidemment
c'est en ligne aussi avec mercy le
parking au logis ce qui vous a visé la
maille et on a écouté le chanceux